c'est devant le parlement que le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson a
annoncé ce lundi la levée du confinement
en outre manche à partir de mercredi
prochain les gens pourront quitter leur
domicile pour n'importe quelle raison et
se rencontrer dans des espaces publics
extérieurs sous réserve de ne pas
dépasser 6 personnes les cérémonies
religieuses
les mariages pourront reprendre et des
magasins les soins de beauté les salles
de sport pourront rouvrir
il s'agit ici d'un assouplissement des
restrictions limitées dans le temps
en vue des fêtes de fin d'année mais
après le confinement du printemps les
londoniens eux restent sur leurs gardes
je m'y attendais depuis le début je
pense que leur objectif était d'ouvrir
et de laisser les gens profitaient de
noël mais maintenant c'est une période
délicate avec les maladies habituel
divers qui circulent
c'est quand même un peu dangereux avec
le co vide je ne pense pas qu'il soit
judicieux d'assouplir les restrictions
juste parce que c'est noël
j'estime que s'il ya des preuves
scientifiques c'est que c'est une bonne
chose à faire si c'est sans danger
alors ok si les restaurants et les pubs
n'avait pas autorisé à ouvrir
il y aurait eu beaucoup de fermetures et
cela aurait signifié la mort de beaucoup
d'entreprises
après tout dont elle est une période de
l'année où beaucoup d'entreprises
réalise la majorité de leur chiffre
d'affaires nous devons donc apprendre à
vivre avec le co vide boris johnson lui
se veut optimiste
le gouvernement britannique compte sur
les vaccins en cours de développement et
les récents progrès en la matière
renforcerait l'espoir d'un retour à la
normale d'ici quelques mois